this time of year the pike are spawning
in the shallows there's a grassy area to
stuff around the corner where I might
find something I haven't caught a pike
yet this year never know exactly what
you're gonna find but I'm hoping for
some good fishing today this is one of
my favorite spots right anywhere these
trees are living out here you got to
learn a lot about what's going on at
different places at different times one
thing I've learned is that if I want to
get a fish at this time of year I go
over this Inlet fish close to the grass
that's where the pike responding right
now oh there's a big one right here
there's a real fat Pike right here I
just saw it right beside the canoe I see
one right there yep yep I see if I can
get him interested in this
there's one chasing it
yep got it
I got a Pike hooked on here oh it's a
nice big one pulling me out it's a nice
big pike I gotta be careful I don't want
this one get away gotta watch out for
those pike have big teeth
got it look at that fish Wow
that's gonna be lunch and dinner
you